[Music]
hey everyone its Johanna here today
we'll be making some easy delicious
gluten-free vegetarian dinners firstly
let's understand what is a gluten-free
diet a gluten-free diet is a diet which
excludes the protein gluten this protein
is found in grains such as wheat barley
rye and cryptically across between wheat
and rye a gluten-free diet is used
primarily to treat people with celiac
disease because gluten causes
inflammation in the small intestines of
people with celiac disease
hence consuming gluten free meals will
help to control the signs and symptoms
of celiac disease and to prevent any
further complications gluten free meals
can also help with people who are gluten
intolerance nowadays gluten free diet is
popular even amongst people who do not
need to go on this diet they are turning
to a gluten-free diet in response to
feeling tired bloated depressed and they
find that by eliminating gluten helps to
make them feel better and to even lose
weight
chances are it's because they are
cutting out excess hidden calories found
in flour-based food and not due to
cutting out gluten if you aim to eat a
balanced meal you will also feel less
bloated and it will also help you
towards your weight loss another
important point to note is that
gluten-free foods do not necessarily
mean healthy or low in calories in fact
gluten-free diet can be nutrient
deficient low in fiber iron vitamin B
and D and many more other essential
nutrients that's because majority of the
gluten-free products are made from
refined and Irish
grains and starches which can be high in
calories with very few minerals and
vitamins so if you plan to go on a
gluten-free diet it is very important
for you to make the extra effort to
consume more vegetables fruits beans
lean meat and more natural gluten free
grains such as rice quinoa and buckwheat
instead of just buying products with
gluten-free label audits my gluten-free
dinners are cooked using mainly
unprocessed natural ingredients so let's
start with my really easy and cheap
recipe which is also part of my lazy
dinner - mutter rice and black beans
this dinner takes less than 15 minutes
to prepare so when I'm feeling tired or
lazy and I want something nutritious and
feeling I will opt for this the
ingredients you need are 1/2 a cup of
uncooked brown or white rice which will
weigh approximately 240 gram once cooked
half a can of chopped tomatoes juice
reserved 1 TSP of olive oil 2 cloves of
garlic minced 1 large bell pepper
chopped half the can of black beans
rinsed and drained 1 teaspoon of ground
cumin 1/2 a teaspoon of chili powder and
a little bit of salt for seasoning the
first step is to cook the rice according
to instructions in a pan heat olive oil
over medium-high heat add garlic and
bell pepper and fry for three to four
minutes until fragrant and bell pepper
starts to soften then mix in the black
beans chili powder cumin and salt and
cook for another 1 minute to combine all
the ingredients together next and half a
can of chopped tomatoes and bring to a
boil under low heat cook for another 5
to 7
until the beans have absorbed much of
the liquid finally mix in the rice and
combine all the ingredients stirring for
one to two minutes until the rice is
warm and it's served immediately why do
I like rice with black beans well
firstly one cup of black beans has 15
grams of satisfying protein and it does
not contain any saturated fat found in
animal protein sources especially red
meat black beans are also a low energy
dense food which means you get to eat
more for less calories this can help you
to avoid overeating and to watch your
calorie intake which can help to with
weight loss ultimate in a healthy weight
and by combining rice and beans to
incomplete proteins on their own they
become a complete protein this one
serving only has 292 calories so try my
lazy and cheap dinner the next recipe is
one of my favorite dishes which is
usually high in calories and fat lasagna
so after gaining inspirations from
several recipes and trying my own
combination with ingredients that I like
I present to you my low calorie
vegetarian quinoa lasagna it looks so
unhealthy but it is so healthy packed
full of vegetables to make this lasagna
the ingredients you need are 1 cup of
water half a cup of quinoa uncooked 2
teaspoons of olive oil 1 medium onion
diced one curve of garlic minced one jar
of basic traditional pasta sauce or
tomato sauce half a block of firm tofu 1
large egg beaten juice from half a lemon
1 large zucchini sliced 1 large bell
pepper slice 1 large carrot diced salt
and pepper for seasoning and half a cup
of grated cheese of your choice
Parmesan cheddar mozzarella pour a
dairy-free cheese in a pan combine water
and quinoa and bring to a boil then
reduce to a simmer cover and cook for 15
minutes while waiting for the quinoa to
cook in a food processor combine the
tofu with an egg and lemon juice blend
for 20 seconds or until you have a
smooth and creamy mixture and set it
aside
once quinoa is cooked block with a fork
and spread the quinoa evenly in an
ovenproof dish now preheat the oven to
180 degrees Celsius or 350 degrees
Fahrenheit in a pan keeps 1 TSP of olive
oil over medium-high heat add onion and
garlic and cooked for three to four
minutes until fragrant and lightly Brown
add the carrots and cook for another
three to four minutes then add the pasta
sauce or tomato sauce stir for three to
four minutes until the sauce is hot
remove from heat and set it aside next
he is the remaining 1 teaspoon of olive
oil over medium-high heat at bell pepper
and zucchini season with salt and pepper
and cook for 10 minutes or until the
vegetables are tender and set it aside
finally let's start to layer our lasagna
spread half of the pasta sauce over the
quinoa make a layer of half of the
vegetables then pour the creamy tofu
mixture then the remaining vegetables
finished with the remaining pasta sauce
and spread cheese evenly on top now it's
time to place it in the oven bake the
lasagne for 30 to 35 minutes and - it's
hot and the cheese is melted bubbling
and slightly brown around the edges then
remove from the oven and allow the
lasagne to cool down
ten minutes before serving here are my
reasons why you should try this instead
of using lasagna noodles which mostly is
included free I've substituted with one
of the world's healthiest food quinoa
most grains are considered incomplete
protein sources because they do not
contain all the essential amino acids
quinoa however is considered a complete
protein source containing all nine
essential amino acids
besides that quinoa contains almost
twice as much fiber in comparison to
most other grains and with all the
vegetables in this lasagna it is packed
full of fiber so this dish will keep you
satisfied for longer and instead of
using the typical white lasagna sauce
which is high in calories and high in
fat I have made my own white sauce using
tofu and egg which is low in calories
high in protein and low in fat if you
are a vegan you can omit the egg which
shouldn't really affect the recipe and
taste by much and you can use dairy-free
cheese zucchini and carrots are low in
calories and high in water content so by
consuming these vegetables you will be
adding to your daily fluid needs most
traditional pasta sauces are gluten-free
but please do read the food label and
check the ingredients just to be sure or
you can make your own sauce with tomato
puree and tomato sauce and a little bit
of mixed herbs so if you are craving for
lasagna but you're concerned about the
high calorie and fat content try my
healthy quinoa lasagna instead this one
serving only has 200 and I think three
point six calories so you can feel good
when eating it
my final dinner on the menu is an Asian
dish chickpeas spinach curry
this is a basic vegetable curry recipe
so feel free to change the vegetables
according to your own preference the
ingredients you'll need are 1/2 an onion
diced 1 clove of garlic crushed 1
teaspoon of curry powder 1 TSP of olive
oil 1 can of chickpeas rinsed and
drained half the can of chopped tomatoes
I'm drained 150 grams of fresh or frozen
spinach 150 gram of fresh or frozen
cauliflower 1/2 a cup of water and salt
and pepper to taste in a pan heat olive
oil over medium-high heat add onion and
garlic and lightly stir fry for 3 to 4
minutes until slightly brown and
fragrant then mix in the curry powder
and a splash of water and cook for
another minute next add the chickpeas
cauliflower tomatoes and season with
salt and pepper cover and allow all the
ingredients to cook for 15 to 20 minutes
stirring occasionally
finally stir in the spinach every mini
water cook for another 5 to 7 minutes or
until spinach is fully wilted and warm
and serve if you like hard spice I have
made this with you in mind this one
serving only has 169 calories you can
serve this with a side of rice or even
baked potato this recipe is also part of
my 90 day weight loss challenge vegan
meal plans so have this as part of a
balanced diet now remember that all my
recipes are always interchangeable so
you can have this for your life as well
well you might ask me should I go under
gluten-free
personally I am not limited to free diet
because there is no need to and I do
enjoy my occasional naughty food your
dietary choice is up to you if you think
that you might have celiac disease or
gluten intolerance do not self diagnose
go to your local doctor to get an
accurate diagnosis of your symptoms if
you want to go on a gluten-free diet do
take the time to consider the extra food
shopping cost and the lifestyle changes
and sacrifices you might have to make
gluten-free or not do try this easy and
delicious dinner recipes and let me know
which is your favorite in the comments
below for new Fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my You Tube channel and
website do you follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter
to stay connected with me thanks guys
[Music]